[Musique]
on se tourne vers les lois mais les lois
ne nous est pas ce soir au quai des
parents qui cherchent leurs enfants
disparus forcés de se battre contre la
bureaucratie la mise à rechercher des
documents pour prouver qu'un maxime
y a vraiment existé constants alors que
papa figure on vous a parlé de ces
nombreux cas d'enfants disparus un peu
partout dans des communautés autochtones
au québec et on continue de suivre ce
dossier parce qu'on découvre que les cas
se multiplient
est ce qu'on apprend également c'est que
les parents doivent se battre contre une
lourde bureaucratie simplement pour
savoir si leurs enfants parfois des
bébés sont décédés ont été donnés en
adoption contre leur gré voici d'abord
en rappelle l'anc est dan panassac et de
sonia desmarais suivi des derniers
développements
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une communauté attikamek
pas une famille qui n'a pas connu la
souffrance de perdre la trace d'un
enfant que l'on soit au pitch et walt
wiimote achiou manawan il suffit de
tendre l'oreille et le micro pour
entendre l'histoire d'enfants volés
faisant un stage mais ne juge el hamdi
que kar kar son bébé est tombé
malavialle un peu près six mois
finalement ils ont réussi à demande un
avion et sont allés à la tuque
diane est évacuée seul sans sa mère
c'était la norme à l'époque elle avait
puni money qui nécessite de la garder un
temps à l'hôpital de la tuque mais elle
s'est volatilisée placé dans une famille
blanche sans le consentement de ses
parents en autres vins documents
services sociaux j'ai vu le papier
placements d'enfants veut vraiment
marquer avant dans des parents
j'emmenais ce document la mama j'ai
traduit le document à se souvenait
qu'elle avait signé un document mais
c'est le curé lui disais c'est pourquoi
puce est soignée autre famille autre
disparition jamais david desservir tout
ce temps l'homme a malgré tout le temps
passé coeur serait vivant jamais tu es
mort mais pourquoi pensez que votre
frère pouvait y vivent à ce que savaient
les quatre soleil puis en plus à la part
des des histoires comme ça lorsque des
enfants qui ont été enlevés
leur avait dit que le raf entame en plus
isolé plutôt été retrouvé ce matin ont
été testés maquis qu'on lui dise cette
amap qu'elle ait pas de calais
la travailleuse sociale and diane a elle
même retrouvé vivant un enfant pourtant
déclaré mort est venu en nombre pour
venir manouane avec moi taylor modique
et amar mais je voudrais savoir où il
est je dirais tu vas chercher des litres
v6 le rapport c'est comme voler quelque
chose une place à lons depuis ce
reportage les attikameks ont continué à
chercher ses enfants volés comme et isme
ils ont multiplié les rencontres et
réalisé que 34 de leurs enfants manquent
à l'appel dans les trois communautés
c'est une cause qui tient qu'un
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont sont décédées et
si oui de quoi
où ont-ils été adopté sans avertir les
parents
on a eu de la misère chercher des
documents pour prouver que maxime et a
vraiment existé
les hôpitaux gares d'un sommaire du
diagnostic et des soins apportés pour
chaque personne hospitalisée d'un
formulaire aller chercher on le remplit
le par enseigne et sont obligés de vous
donner l'information
mais surprise des hôpitaux refusent de
fournir les archives médicales aux
parents pour leurs propres enfants
on se tourne vers les lois mais les lois
ne nous aide pas ne nous protège pas
qu'est ce qui nous reste sans preuve de
décès les hôpitaux considère que
l'enfant recherché est aujourd'hui un
adulte et que c'est à lui de demander
son dossier médical
mais les parents n'ont justement pas de
preuves de décès c'est sans issue
à la mi-janvier désespérée des
attikameks ont décidé de faire le chemin
jusqu'à ottawa pour fouiller dans les
archives du canada à la recherche des
responsables ou de directive ce come
back des réponses que 10000 break jeu
des chefs de famille traditionnelle ou
tenu à venir en soutien
ils ont tous perdu la trace d'un enfant
noir de 2 voici la boîte qui contient
des documents que vous avez demandé à
consulter aujourd'hui les familles mise
sur ce petit espoir pour pallier le
silence bureaucratique des hôpitaux
caché dans ces milliers de pages
retrouver un courrier concernant leurs
enfants est ce que vous avez trouvé
quelque chose
gouvernement ici c'est intéressant à
l'avenir toute évacuation des familles
vers les hôpitaux devra être autorisée
par les directeurs deux ans par enfant
nous trouvons des documents officiels
sur les responsables mais pas de trace
des enfants en particulier pour obliger
les autorités à bouger les attikameks
ont décidé de porter plainte à la police
pour disparitions de personnes
nous avons appris que là est ce qu a
créé une unité spéciale pour enquêter
je ne pars tous les enfants qui disparut
puis on doit se battre jusqu'à temps
qu'on trouve nos qu'est ce qu'on veut
savoir
[Musique]